karies ist echt eine geißel der
menschheit laut
weltgesundheitsorganisation die hsk ist
tatsächlich eine der größten
gesundheitsgefahren für die menschen in
den industrieländern verursacht durch
bakterien und befeuert durch zucker den
wir täglich zu uns nehmen entstehen die
löcher in den zähnen und jetzt sollen es
tatsächlich möglich sein sich gegen
karies impfen zu lassen wie der
impfstoff funktioniert ob er eine
allzweckwaffe gegen karies ist und ob
jetzt endlich schluss mit dem lästigen
zähneputzen ist jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
streptococcus mutans alleine der name
des bakteriums klingt fürchterlich und
alle die schon einmal löcher in den
zähnen hatten wissen dass dieser name
des karrees erregers völlig zu recht
einen so angsteinflößenden klang hat die
bakterien treiben nicht nur im mund von
denjenigen unter uns sehr unwesen dies
mit der zahnhygiene nicht so genau
nehmen auch menschen die zwei bis
dreimal täglich zähne putzen dann noch
zahnseide benutzen und außerdem noch
mundspülungen machen haben nicht selten
mit karies zu kämpfen doch damit könnte
jetzt schluss sein denn einem
forschungsteam aus china ist jetzt wohl
das gelungen was wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler schon seit rund 60
jahren versuchen einen impfstoff gegen
die bakterien zu entwickeln in der
vergangenheit konnte bereits schon
einmal ein effektiver wirkstoff gefunden
werden doch immer zeigten sich
ungewollte nebenwirkungen wie etwa
entzündungen das chinesische
forschungsteam knüpfte an frühere
studien an in denen man versucht hat er
verschiedene proteine zu verschmelzen
ihr ziel dabei streptococcus mutans
letztendlich daran gehindert werden an
die zelle anzudocken und tatsächlich
durch die kombination von verschiedenen
proteinen konnten die nebenwirkung laut
der aktuellen chinesischen studie
minimiert werden doch die wirkung wie
behalten den tierversuchen bei denen der
impfstoff mäusen und ratten über die
nasen verabreicht wurde verhinderte der
entwickelte impfstoff in knapp 65
prozent der fälle ein carius ausbruch
bei rund der hälfte der tiere die mit
dem erreger infiziert waren konnten die
erkrankung geheilt werden jetzt stehen
erst einmal weitere tests an bevor der
impfstoff wohl millionen menschen auf
der welt helfen könnte und zwar nicht
nur menschen in industrieländern die
durch übermäßigen zuckerkonsum carius
bekommen haben sondern auch betroffenen
in entwicklungsländern
denn dort haben die menschen teilweise
keinen zugang zu frischem wasser
zahnbürsten und zahnpasta zudem fehlt
oft das wissen bezüglich einer
effektiven zahnhygiene doch alle die
jetzt glauben dass dieser impfstoff uns
irgendein man einmal vom lästigen
zähneputzen befreien wird die muss ich
enttäuschen das betont dass chinesische
forschungsteam selbst der impfstoff ist
lediglich als eine ergänzung zur
täglichen zahnpflege gedacht denn eines
steht fest der streptococcus ist nicht
der einzige übeltäter mund durch den um
stoff wird er zwar gewinnt
sich auf der oberfläche der zähne
festzusetzen dennoch kann er sich weiter
im und ausbreiten den final besiegt wird
er dich diesen impfstoff nicht da sage
ich mal noch nicht wie die menschheit an
den pocken gezeigt hat ist sie in der
lage krankheiten vollkommen auszurotten
nur bei den masern da hakt es im moment
weil egoismus und dummheit
flächendeckende impfungen verhindert
aber da kommen wir wahrscheinlich durch
impfpflicht dem ziel näher ich sehe da
durchaus eine verheißungsvolle zukunft
sein werden der höchstwahrscheinlich
immer mal wieder von großen auch
tödlichen epidemie heimgesucht aber
impfstoffe werden wohl immer schneller
und effektiver gefunden werden ein
riesen thema auf jeden fall jeweils um
halte ich euch dazu natürlich auf dem
laufenden wenn ihr kein video zum thema
und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesse nicht den
genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter
mit super bazillus aufgetaucht fachleute
befürchten pandemie da geht es um einen
wirklich ziemlich tödlichen super
bazillus der eine pandemie auslösen
könnte gerade wurde er entdeckt extrem
spannendes video also nicht verpassen
und draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran